las autoridades ucranianas se han
anunciado el comienzo de una
contraofensiva para retomar el control
de la provincia de gerson especialmente
su capital la ciudad de gerson que fue
la primera capital de provincia en caer
en control de las fuerzas rusas el
pasado 2 de marzo desde entonces
permanece allí hermanos el 35% de la
población las fuerzas de Moscú han
tratado de afianzar el control en esta
ciudad y se prevé que los próximos meses
realicen un referéndulo que ha llevado a
que las fuerzas ucranianas quieran
acelerar el contrato tomar el control de
la ciudad y por eso ha pedido a la
población que pueda que evacúe la ciudad
para ellos poder realizar esta ofensiva
con mayor tranquilidad la única manera
que tiene esta población de salir es a
través de una carretera que une los
límites de la población de la provincia
de zaporilla es una línea invisible
entre las fuerzas rusas que tienen el
control del Sur esta provincia con la
parte más del Norte y tienen que
transitar esta carretera hasta llegar a
este lugar de acogida que fue famoso en
su momento porque aquí llegaban todas
las personas que huían de la ciudad de
Mario Ponce Y esa sería sobre el mar de
Pues aquí empiezan a llegar cada vez con
más frecuencia personas que vienen de
gerson contando historias igual bastante
trágicas dicen que hay 500 coches al
menos esperando del lado ruso pasar aquí
también hablan de ataques a las personas
que logran cruzar esa transcurso gris un
lugar donde nadie tiene el control y
donde las fuerzas rusas suelen atacar a
quienes la transitan